um talk to me about red man man CU I I I
think somehow he's turned out to be one
of the more slept on rappers ever cuz
he's one of the greatest of all time um
and I think like you know I just saw the
the reaction online from some of the
young people that when Killer Mike won
his Grammy which he deserved to win at
48 and he deserved to win it cuz he had
the best rap bbum of the year last year
um but I feel like these days like a guy
like red man like you know when I'm
growing up like Red Man's like the goat
you know I mean like Muddy Waters and
there's a dark side and blackout and go
on and on and on Death Squad what was it
like kind of like uh being around Red
Man early like what did you see in him
that um you know kind of had you bring
him into the
fold just the the the metaphors the way
that he Rhymes know the word play
everything about me was as far as
um the rappers that I was able to get
like do effects in them as everybody was
Keith muray everybody had something
different Keith Murray had the the big
words she had you know I got AIDS [__]
you know the Eminem what emem lik about
you know far as had crazy they do effect
changed the game
because you had all these groups that
either emulated them or made records
doing the IG and when you get a call
from Ice Cube saying you want you know
what that fix this is Cube calling you
know what I'm saying to put them on the
record you know that these guys are
making an impact so but again but
Reggie it was this that I think that I I
saw him at a a club in nework called
Sensations and he was with do it all
from Lords of the
Underground do it all rhymed and Reggie
was his
DJ crazy right but then again he became
Lo underground later on but yeah he's
like my man rap and regie had one line
he said I float like a butter F sting
like the rock group I thought it was
going to be like you know like a s like
a bee yeah but he the metaphor went
float like a butterfly sting like a rock
group so autom make I'm like yo Nobody
Does this right at this time
199 one or two crazy he was already
ahead you know so I I I talked to him
and it was fast I'm like yo he reie was
so ill
that I gave him my number but not I
didn't write it down he remembered it he
remembered it that's how it used to be
back in the day though you might meet a
girl in the mall and like she'll tell
you her number but she won't write it
down and it's like and and he said it it
took a couple of days for him to realize
what the number was and a few days later
he called the phone but he he had to
remember the
number that's crazy what was that
conversation like like I'm trying to n
just like it wasn't no C me I'm just I'm
a nonot person so at the end of the day
like yo you want to do this and plus
he's a he's already a fan he don't
believe this is happening like oh [__]
I'm I'm on the phone with Eric he's
inviting me over yeah so that that was
it that's crazy man um how do you feel
about like uh cuz I feel like hip-hop
these days is like I always tell people
if you want to find good [__] you got to
like it's there you just have to it's
just not being pushed like like we just
talked about the killer mic thing but in
terms of like um you know you've been
wrapped up in certain like hip-hop uh
beef situations and nowadays it's I feel
like it's it almost might be more
Amplified these days than it was back
then because back then you had to go
spend money to pick up the source and or
or the or the vibe magazine and read the
interview in which a rapper was calling
out another rapper or go buy a DVD or
whatever these days you just open your
phone and there's 30 blogs talking about
whatever conflict's going on like like
how do you feel about like the current
state of like hip-hop in terms of the
media that kind of stuff I
mean listen to me it made it accessible
to everybody which is a cool thing right
but I just think that um the
oversaturation the music took the
excitement away from it definitely you
know as far as something coming out and
something like waiting for Tuesday W for
two yeah waiting for that though too but
to make a long story short I feel like
to
me music is making a a comeback and if
if people aren't seeing that then
they're going to be in trouble because
I'm here with you at this time in my
career yeah making music and and I'm
gonna make sure that the music is what
we know music to be like I'm not trying
to to um play the game of what everybody
else is doing everybody already doing
that and people are getting tired and
it's being proven um the
sampling that hit makers doing meanwhile
like taking CRA old records is changing
the tempo back who care if it's Foxy
Brown the Temple's back who cares if
it's um Brandy um and mace the Temple's
back so that's what's changing the game
even if they are sampling it's still
changing people don't realize the tempo
like yeah it's like like the 85 to like
100 BPM records are like far and few
between these days it's like but it's
changing so that means that music is
going to be put back in the Forefront of
what music feels like to feel good to to
just sold to make you who who if they
still dancing cuz I went to a party
whatever they just sitting there with
their phones and and Bottles standing at
the in their sections there not a lot of
dancing anymore girls ain't talking to
guys guys ain't talking to girls like
what type of [__] is this this is what
we living in but I just feel that at
this time music is making a change
that's why that's why everybody's
coming we ain't going to name no artist
though but a lot of artists came out and
[__] up and they had to go back in the
studio and make rap records a lot of
people well I wanted shout out uh 21
Savage just put out an album that was
heavy on substance heavy on raps and a
lot of people wouldn't have I mean I I I
I I've kind of paid attention to his
Evolution over the years but his new
album is crazy Kev what we talking about
is not foreign the game is done shifted
I agree and and if people don't wake up
they're going to be in trouble they're
going to get left at the bus stop man
exactly mhm and I'm not sitting here to
be be hating and the ho and this and
this and that this is just the way it's
at and we and there's there's moves
being made that people don't know about
yet that that um that some of the the
people that we know the powers that be
aren't going to be in there yeah and
they about to move this thing forward so
now
Talent it's going to with no no
algorithms no how many likes you got
none of that stuff it's all about are
you ill and are you dope that's where we
headed to that's how it used to be as
you know when I was growing up it was
like yo of course it was it was about
the bars it was about who had the crazy
you know Neil Armstrong freestyle you
know like but all the big
writers like my man got a group coming
out to this um sound with ushers the
girl what's the girl name but not
simeons yeah the simeons but they didn't
go to the new people they went to the
Brian Michael coxes the dreams the the
you know the these people who write mhm
music yeah like the money love song this
is where this is where we're going even
Victoria mon what she did she wrote a
incredible record czy no for sure so so
this is where we at somebody who took
her 15 years he said so again the talent
is going to outweigh the popularity this
is where we at and people can this is
where we going so and so I just me being
out to I give my assessment on what I
feel for young people to know because
this this is important I don't come
because I'm the I'm a person who's who's
the so-called overhead right you know I
never been broke in my life never going
to be so I I don't come from a point
where somebody who's mad because I'm not
in the game no you're you been yeah you
ain't never went nowhere I'm in it to
also let you know that in for 35 years
when you get called you can go you can
go perform somebody come and watch you
yeah this new er is nobody coming to see
them so they didn't save or have some do
something for them that person who turns
our age is not going to be trying to go
see [__] [__] ass [__] whatever it
won't match no I I I say this and like I
don't you know 50 is obviously uh
generation after you but uh I just went
to the 50 concert right the tour and I
was just like God I missed this like
people not rapping over their [__]
tracks like you know what I mean that's
the we that's the czy too and some
veterans are doing that I'm like where
you Lear that how you rhing over the
beat we did that it's crazy so so so so
this um Showmanship yeah all this comes
into play again with all the tours
that's going the new people is
struggling all the veterans sold
out M sold out 50 c sold out every the
Beyonce everybody that's the veteran had
no problem touring yeah 100%